[Music]
welcome back if you've been wondering
about the future of obamacare our law
vegas now expert eric palacios joined us
with an update take a look
eric welcome back thanks for having me
so we don't have you know a shortage of
healthcare information on this show but
let's talk about specifically obamacare
um what's the update on the supreme
court deciding what they're going to do
about it
well it's a difficult uh case to decide
it's been up in front of
the supreme court twice already this is
the third time and now
the issue is uh whether it's
constitutional to continue the act based
on the fact
that it's mandatory to everyone now
originally the court held
that it was constitutional because
congress had a right to do this
because the penalty to not do it was a
tax and congress has the right to tax
so it passed that time but then congress
eliminated this
tax or reduced it to zero so now the
argument is
if the care act was found to be
constitutional based on the tax and now
the
tax is basically eliminated the whole
affordable care act should be
done away with and we have to start new
from scratch so the court has to decide
uh what they're going to do there's an
argument that it could just
sever that provision and do away with
that as unconstitutional but continue
with the rest of the act but we're going
to have to wait and see
all right well what will the court
likely do in your opinion
they will probably do that is separate
say although this clause or this part of
it
uh was unconstitutional or can't be
enforced the rest of it
uh will continue to go forward and they
will likely base
if they make that decision based on what
was congress's intent
when they reduced the tax to zero
obviously they didn't do it to eliminate
the act altogether otherwise they would
have
voted to do that and tried to do that
they just uh voted to
reduce the tax uh to zero so if you go
based on what was congress's intent it
was probably to keep the act
uh we'll see if the court follows that
okay
definitely a complicated topic when will
the court decide do you know
well they heard arguments uh this week
on tuesday uh but
we likely will have an answer by early
summer
okay well then we'll just have to keep
checking on in on this topic and with
you
very good we'll see you next week thank
you so much eric have a good one
for more information give eric palacios
and associates a call at 702
702-444-7777